Previously, we have just been setting
the position of objects based
on how much time has elapsed.
Basically, the x position is
some function of time, and
the y position is some
other function of time.
More interesting, however, is to set
the position of objects based on
their position in the previous
frame using their velocity.
If we just do that,
however, we just get motion at
a constant speed in a straight line.
To get really interesting motion,
we need to take into account
acceleration as well.
Acceleration is the change
in velocity over time.
Let's take the simple
case of a falling object.
Let's say we've got some
object in freefall.
And last frame, its position was x and
y, and its velocity was vX and vY.
To figure out where it
will be this frame,
we first need to update its velocity.
vX will be unchanged since gravity
is only acting vertically.
To find its new vertical velocity,
we need to add the elapsed time of this
frame, multiply it by
the acceleration due to gravity.
We can then use these new velocities
to update the position of
the following object.
In the next exercise,
we'll see these equations in action.